CAST
And... action!
SHANG-CHI
How's it going?
Get off of me!
KATY
Does he look like he can fight?
♪♪
SIMU LIU
The moment that I was cast for Shang-Chi
I was like nervous-slash-anxious
-slash-excited.
Never thought that I would
be Marvel's first Asian superhero.
KATY
Wow, you're really good.
SIMU LIU
I showed up for the first day of training
and I just got my butt kicked.
Ow! Panic at the disco!
We explored what his strengths were,
we also covered all his weaknesses.
[Laughing]
The training that he went through
mirrored the character.
SIMU LIU
The sets were incredible.
Everything has been carefully designed.
KATY
No, screw you, I'm not doing this!
CREW
Fall!
SIMU LIU
[Laughing]
I'm working with some
of the best in the business.
MICHELLE YEOH
I've never seen a superhero
that looks something like me.
AWKWAFINA
Movies like this allows kids
to feel the possibilities.
SIMU LIU
It was such a profound moment
for me as fan,
as an actor, as an Asian person.
♪♪